es excelente estar de vuelta aquí en
Vila una nación una región que conoce
mejor que nadie las puede transformar o
transformador de la Libertad
[Aplausos]
que le mosto al mundo que la fuerza de
las personas un día no se puede negar y
junto con sus hermanos y hermanas en
Estonia Islandia ayudaron terminar con
una era de división a través del poder
de la conexión
de Berlín sino
la manera del Báltico se volvió el
símbolo para el futuro de Europa y
después pero su independencia y la gente
dijo no
y en enero de 1991
miles y miles de ciudadanos desarmados
vinieron por su propia cuenta
se levantaron como uno para proteger la
torre para proteger al consejo supremo y
defender la libertad 14 Héroes Perdieron
su vida trágicamente cientos resultan
heridos pero todo el mundo vio
que décadas de opresión no habían hecho
nada para apaciguar la llama la Libertad
en este país
y lo digo en serio
eso tiene esas consecuentes la luz del
lutiano luana es fuerte y la mantuvieron
encendida aquí en vilna y en Washington
DC donde las cosas su bandera ondea
todos los días este año pasado
celebramos 100 años de relaciones
diplomáticas ininterrumpidas entre los
Estados Unidos y los Estados bálticos
América América nunca reconoció la
ocupación soviética del Báltico nunca
nunca nunca
[Aplausos]
además tiene un excelente presidente
levántate
[Aplausos]
el lazo entre lituania el pueblo
americano nunca va a flaquear y varios
meses después
el
primer visitante
que tiene el pasaporte de lidera con
visas en este estado
renacido
con el presidente de Chicago Illinois y
sus familias sin estar orgullosas de
este logro
Los Ángeles fue después de eso
mucho pasó después miren
muchos abordaron ese avión y huyeron de
los primeros años de la presión
soviética y están maravillados con
regresar este estado independiente
este día es como una resurrección para
nosotros este día es como una resolución
para nosotros era la cita en serio Esa
es la sensación y así lo fue una
resurrección que rápidamente se
convirtió en una revelación y la nación
que hoy en día es un Fortín de libertad
y la oportunidad de un miembro orgulloso
de la Unión Europea y de la otan
[Aplausos]
tuve el honor como senador de los
Estados Unidos defender a Ucrania y
otros estados del Báltico para que se
unieran a la otan en 2004 no fui
brillante siendo esto
piensen en Cómo esto cambiar las cosas
piensen lo que ha pasado ahora
mis últimos días como presidente de los
Estados Unidos tengo el honor de
participar en la Cumbre histórica de la
otan auspiciada por
hospeda por lituania donde le damos la
bienvenida a Finlandia y la vamos a dar
la bienvenida a Suecia lo antes posible
a la alianza
el presidente erdogan mantuvo su palabra
vimos su travesía histórica y con
orgullo llamó a lituania amiga socia y
aliada aliada aliada
[Aplausos]
pronto la otan será
para tener 32 miembros libres
independientes Unidos para defender
nuestras personas a nuestros ciudadanos
y nuestros territorios Más allá de todo
eso Unidos por valores democráticos para
fortalecernos y por nuestros juramento
sagrado
es un juramento sagrado un ataque contra
uno es un ataque contra todos Porque
todos los miembros de la otan sabe que
la fortaleza de nuestro pueblo y el
poder de la unidad no se puede negar
si son optimistas porque lo soy
lo principal forma de seguridad global
estabilidad la otan es más fuerte más
enérgica y sí más unida que cualquier
otro punto de su historia y más vital
para nuestro futuro compartido No
sucedió por error no
fue Inevitable cuando producen cuando
Putin desató esta guerra brutal contra
Ucrania
él esperaba que la otan se deshiciera
él creyó que nuestra unidad se iba a
resquebrajar con la primera prueba él
creía que los líderes democráticos Pero
se equivocó
enfrentados que La amenaza
[Aplausos]
enfrentados con La amenaza de la paz y
el mundial los valores democráticos que
valoramos tanto la Libertad en sí misma
nosotros Hicimos lo que siempre hacemos
los Estados Unidos
se puso al frente nuestros socios en
Europa también y en el argentino
Pacífico también alrededor del mundo
todo el mundo se levantó y estuvo listo
estábamos listos porque estábamos Unidos
y en los meses antes de la guerra a
medida que don putín agrupar sus fuerzas
en la frontera con Ucrania y se
preparaba para esta invasión brutal yo
estaba en contacto constante con mis con
otros líderes en 7 y en la otan Europea
alrededor del mundo sabíamos lo que está
creando Putin
y nos aseguramos de que la otan
estuviera preparada para disuadir
cualquier agresión en contra de
cualquier estado miembro
Tuvimos una jornada diplomática intensa
con Rusia para tratar de detenerse
Guerra y cuando pensaba que las bombas
rusas no dudamos en actuar
que apoyar al pueblo valiente de Europa
de un planeamientos defendía su país con
increíble dignidad
[Aplausos]
Y eso lo digo desde el fondo de mi
corazón piensen en eso piensen en lo que
están haciendo después de año y medio de
que las fuerzas rusas cometieran
atrocidades brutales de lesa humanidad
la gente de Ucrania no se ha quebrantado
Ucrania sigue siendo independiente sigue
siendo libre y los Estados Unidos a
construir una coalición de más de 50
años para asegurarse de que Ucrania se
defienda a sí misma Ahora hay que lo
pueda seguir haciendo en el futuro
también desde que empezó esta guerra
pues pasan ahora con el presidente
Para que Washington y quiebre y
Hiroshima y ahora en Vila para
declararle al mundo lo que dije
anteriormente nosotros no vamos a
flaquear no vamos a flaquear
lo digo nuestro compromiso con Ucrania
no se va a debilitar vamos a apoyar
libertad
hoy y mañana y todo el tiempo que sea
necesario
Todos queremos que termine esta guerra
en los términos justos
que apoyen los principios básicos de la
carta de las Naciones Unidas que todos
firmamos la soberanía integridad
territorial
Estos son dos Pilares
de las relaciones pacíficas entre las
naciones un país No no se puede permitir
a un país que sea propio por la fuerza
del territorio sus vecinos Rusia podría
terminar esta guerra mañana a retirar
sus fuerzas de Ucrania
y reconociendo las fronteras
internacionales y cesando los ataques
estos ataques inhumanos
por Rusia en Ucrania en contra de sus
mujeres y niños
contra sus fuerzas militares
desafortunadamente Rusia
hasta el momento no ha mostrado ningún
interés en el desenlace diplomático
Putin todavía que puede aguantar más que
Ucrania
no puede creerlo es su tierra su país Su
futuro y aún después de todo este tiempo
Putin todavía duda de nuestro poderío
todavía sigue apostando erróneamente que
la convicción y la unidad entre los
Estados Unidos y nuestros aliados se va
a desintegrar todavía no entiende que
nuestro compromiso nuestros valores y
nuestra libertad es algo que nunca nunca
nunca
puede alejarse esto es Quiénes somos lo
digo en serio es Quiénes somos
es Quiénes somos
las personas los ciudadanos de lituania
junto con nuestros hermanos de El
Báltico son los primeros en defender los
derechos de Ucrania y que pueda tener un
futuro que ellos mismos decían uno que
sea libre Porque si uno vive durante
cierto tiempo sin libertad muchos de
ustedes que son mayores saben mejor que
nadie lo precioso que es por determinar
su propio futuro es precioso o Preciado
para todas las personas en todas partes
no solo en Ucrania Bielorrusia
Georgia en todos los lugares alrededor
del mundo donde las personas continúan
luchando para hacer oír su voz Entonces
mi mensaje mi mensaje para todos es
sigan así siendo que están haciendo
siguen recordando al mundo
la esperanza que representa el lituania
esto lo que usted representan esperanza
en este país y lo digo en serio
no estoy bromeando lo digo sinceramente
nunca debemos olvidar
lo importante que es esto y nunca nunca
Rendirse
en la posibilidad de un mejor mañana la
defensa de la libertad no funciona en un
día en un año es el llamado de nuestra
vida de toda la vida
estamos aquí preparados para la lucha
que se avecina la unidad no se va a
derrumbar se los prometo
a medida que miro alrededor del mundo en
este momento en un momento de guerra y
peligro momentos de competencia
incertidumbre también veo momento de
oportunidad sin precedentes una
oportunidad sin precedentes oportunidad
de avanzar realmente hacia un mundo con
mayor paz y mayor prosperidad libertad y
dignidad
justicia igualitaria bajo la ley
derechos humanos libertades
fundamentales que son la bendición el
derecho por nacimiento de toda la
humanidad es ese es el mundo es el cual
está trabajando los Estados Unidos y es
uno que solo lograremos si lo hacemos
juntos y me refiero juntos tenemos que
tomar el mismo espíritu de la unidad
propósito común determinación que se ha
demostrado en esta respuesta a la
agresión de Rusia Ucrania y e incluir a
nuestros socios a medida que continuamos
construido el mundo que queremos vivir y
el mundo que queremos dejarle a nuestros
hijos amigos
a nivel más fundamental damos una
elección enfrentamos una elección la
elección entre un mundo definido para la
coerción explotación
donde la fuerza hace el derecho o un
mundo donde reconocemos que nuestro
propio éxito está ligado al éxito de los
demás Cuando los demás les va mejor a
nosotros también nos va mejor cuando
entendemos que los retos que enfrentamos
hoy
de La amenaza asistencial del cambio
climático para construir una economía
mundial donde nadie quiere rezagado
que son demasiado grandes para que una
sola nación lo resuelva por su propia
cuenta y para lograr nuestras metas y
cumplir los retos de esta era Tenemos
que trabajar juntos y lo digo
Honestamente el mundo está cambiando
Tenemos la oportunidad de cambiar la
dinámica
por eso me he enfocado tanto como
presidente en revitalizar y reconstruir
las alianzas son la piedra angular del
liderazgo en el mundo estos últimos años
hicimos la alianza transitrática la
llevamos a nuevas alturas estamos
reafirmando la importancia entre la
alianza entre Europa y los Estados
Unidos como un ancla para la estabilidad
global la idea de que los Estados Unidos
pueda prosperar sin una Europa segura No
es razonable también
en verdad en verdad no es no es no estoy
bromeando
también elevamos la alianza del lindo
Pacífico con Japón la República de Corea
Australia las filipinas
la cual les proporciona seguridad
crítica y disuasión en esa Región del
mundo a nuestra asociación con Australia
India Japón los Estados Unidos estamos
teniendo
o uniendo a las democracias principales
de la región para que cooperen y el
Pacífico siga siendo libre próspero y
seguro demostramos durante esta cumbre
de la otan con socios de lindo Pacífico
que se unen a nosotros por segunda vez
consecutiva estamos trabajando las
condiciones más profundas centros
democracias de la región del Indo
Pacífico para trabajar juntos hacia los
valores compartidos que todos buscamos
alianzas fuertes
asociaciones Versátiles propósito común
acción colectiva
para suplir los retos compartidos el
mundo se ha encogido
Así es como construimos un segundo pero
compartimos y sabemos que compartimos
los retos y trabajamos juntos tenemos
que
estar preparados juntos Estableciendo la
comisión para fortalecer y defender las
reglas más básicas del camino para
preservar todos los beneficios
extraordinarios que salen de aquí y que
se afianzan el el Estado de derecho
Tenemos que trabajar juntos para
proteger los derechos y libertades
todas las ideas del comercio también y
que han permitido décadas de crecimiento
mundial sí la integridad territorial y
la soberanía pero también principios
como libertad de navegación sobre vuelo
mantener nuestros cielos y mares
compartidos abiertos para todas las
naciones con acceso igualitario
a medida que continuamos explorando esta
edad de nuevas posibilidades
una
que la permiten los avances en la
innovación
debemos garantizar que los espacios
comunes en nuestro futuro reflejen las
aspiraciones más altas para nosotros y
para otros como diría mi padre que todo
el mundo tenga algo de dignidad entonces
con la Inteligencia artificial
ingeniería biológica y otras tecnologías
emergentes de ingeniería
no se hacen en las armas de la opresión
sino utilizar estas herramientas de
oportunidad trabajar con nuestros
aliados Esto es para construir una
cadena de suministro que sea más
resistente más segura para que nunca más
se enfrente a una situación como la que
tuvimos durante la pandemia donde no
pudimos obtener los bienes críticos que
necesitamos para nuestra vida diaria
saben
casi firmamos
un documento común para lidiar con esta
amenaza asistencial de acelerar el
cambio climático real es serio no
tenemos mucho tiempo
es la amenaza la única amenaza principal
a la humanidad si no trabajamos juntos
para prevenir no vamos a Evitar que las
consecuencias climático acaben con
nuestro futuro el de nuestros niños
también tenemos que reconocer la
responsabilidad compartida para ayudar a
destrabar el enorme potencial que existe
en los países de bajos y menos ingresos
alrededor del mundo no por caridad
sino porque también nos interesa a
nosotros
todos nos beneficiamos cuando más socios
trabajan juntos hacia metas compartidas
todos beneficiamos cuando las personas
son más saludables y más prósperas no es
una exageración es cierto todos nos
beneficiamos con más emprendedores
innovadores cuando pueden perseguir sus
sueños para mejor mañana
Entonces tenemos que actualizar nuestra
caja de herramientas
mejor traemos hoy en este mundo
interconectado pandemias conflictos
desastres naturales hace que sea más
difícil resolver los problemas de
pobreza inestabilidad y retiene a tantas
personas por eso los Estados Unidos está
liderando un esfuerzo para transformar
los bancos de desarrollo multilateral
como el Banco Mundial ayudar a resolver
mejor los retos globales mientras que Se
incrementa la misión central de reducir
la pobreza
e impulsar la prosperidad compartida
todos estamos trabajando juntos con
nuestros socios en el g7
para enfrentar las enormes necesidades
de infraestructura de altos estándares
alrededor del mundo especialmente en
países de bajos ingleses bajos y menos
ingresos en África América Latina y el
sueste séptico trabajar juntos en el
mundo que queremos construir juntos
damas y caballeros
estamos en un punto de inflexión un
punto de inflexión en la historia donde
la lección es las lecciones que tomamos
hoy en día van a formar la elección del
mundo en becas el mundo ha cambiado
cuando
nos volteamos para revisar
qué mundo queremos mañana si podemos
detener la crisis climática antes de que
sea demasiado tarde si podemos
aprovechar las nuevas tecnologías para
avanzar en la libertad o si lo vamos a
disminuir
si avanzamos con más oportunidades
o si se le permite a la inestabilidad de
la inequidad que persista más lugares
cómo vamos a responder estas preguntas
va a determinar el tipo de futuro que
nuestros hijos y nietos van a tener Y de
nuevo no es una exageración es un hecho
va a requerir de todos nosotros de todos
nosotros Yo creo que con ambición
confianza nosotros mismos y en los unos
y los otros Las Naciones trabajando
juntas para una causa en común podemos
responder estas preguntas podemos
garantizar que la visión que compartimos
y la libertad que valoramos no solamente
para no sea solamente para las vacías
sino un mapa de ruta y lo dijo lo dijo
en serio un mapa de ruta un plan de
acciones urgentes para el futuro que
vamos a alcanzar o alcanzar si
trabajamos juntos
amigos
el camino por delante es difícil es
barretar
Tenemos que tener fe los unos a nosotros
y nunca rendirnos nunca perder la
esperanza nunca todos los días tenemos
que tomar la decisión todos los días
Tenemos que sacar fuerzas para pararnos
para defender lo que está bien para lo
que es cierto para defender la libertad
para estar juntos Esta es la elección
que aprendimos de la historia y la
historia de Luis el
Esto es algo que se ve todos los días y
Esto va a determinar va a determinar
Cómo se verá Ucrania es ahora
es cómo cómo vamos a trabajar cómo vamos
a reescribir el futuro Paz luz
posibilidad para todos todos en todas
partes
amigos
es algo que ha habido muchas veces en mi
país nunca nunca en toda mi carrera
estamos optimista con los prospectos del
futuro nunca nunca
entonces Déjenme agradecerles por
tomarse el tiempo de estar aquí para
escuchar Dios los bendiga a todos y que
Dios proteja
a los la libertad y los protectores de
libertad en Ucrania aquí en todas las
naciones del mundo en todas partes
Que Dios proteja nuestras tropas gracias
gracias